how do you distinguish between past
present and future is there really an
order to time does it only move forward
does it move in any direction at all
stop the clock
abandon all assumptions and try to stay
calm this mind-blowing experiment will
only take a few minutes whatever that
means
this is what if and here's how time
could be an illusion in 1915 Albert
Einstein published his general theory of
relativity which changed changes and
will change the way we perceive time in
this groundbreaking theory he proposed
that the laws of physics are the same
for all non accelerating observers this
basically explains why if you were to
watch a car drive past you you would
interpret the cars passengers as moving
at the same speed as the car since their
speed is relative to your position as an
observer on still ground meanwhile
inside the car the passengers feel like
stationary objects since their motion
matches the cars motion relative to the
outside world but while Einstein's
theory of relative motion could be
applied to all objects in the universe
he also realized that one exception to
relativity was light light always moves
at a constant speed these two principles
led Einstein to conceive of a link
between time and space also known as
space-time and one of its tricky
implications is that the perception of
how time passes can be different between
two observers depending on how much
faster one is moving compared to the
other so if it's possible for two
observers to have two accurate
perspectives of times passing but for
those perspectives to be different whose
clock is right and whose is wrong oddly
enough they're both right after all the
fact that different time zones exist are
enough proof that your watch and
someone's watch across the world will
read different times every second of the
day we're inclined to think of the
passing of time as objective or
universal since humans have all more or
less agreed on the same system to
organize our busy lives and to be on the
same page with our neighbors
either next-door or a few countries over
but while time is a convenient tool for
keeping track of the past present and
future the true nature of time is
trickier to grasp once you realize that
the past present and future could all
exist at once when you look up at the
sky you might be able to point out
Proxima Centauri after the Sun Proxima
Centauri is the closest star to earth
and it's only about 4 light years away
so the light you see now is actually 4
years old in our time
if Proxima Centauri exploded we wouldn't
know about it until 4 years later that's
because the speed of light is constant
no matter where you are in the universe
another thing you need to know is the
faster you move the slower time does
this explains how astronaut scott kelly
spent a year in space and came back to
earth 13 milliseconds younger than his
twin now with these two examples let's
put an astronaut on a planet that's 4
light years away that means his present
is unfolding 4 years ahead of you
anything you do now on earth is already
in his past put simply the past present
and future all exist at once
now before you have an existential
crisis there's a theory that might make
living in the past present and future
all at once a little easier it's called
moving spotlight theory and it basically
argues that there is only one absolute
present which changes moment by moment
as if a spotlight is moving over it so
with that information you can begin to
see how the passage of time might be an
illusion there's no single objective
past objective present or objective
future the illusion of time is crafted
by our memories and our experiences and
our upcoming plans which help us
organize our life into a neat sequence
of events but depending on where you are
or how fast you're moving that sequence
will be very very different so whether
you're new age or nostalgic or if you
just prefer the present moment don't
worry there's a place for you somewhere
in the universe it might take you
hundreds of years to get there but if
you move fast enough you'll get there in
no time
you